obsessed with Tik Tok live I think all
three of you should build on Tik Tok
live I think a lot more people need to
use social media lives the way streamers
use twitch everybody doesn't go live
because they think they have to do
something I think you should go live
while you're eating lunch oh that's what
I do tell I do I do live sometimes on
Tik Tok where it's just me eating and
talking to people for like two hours and
and as you know and then my jeans are in
the background because I'm usually in my
showroom and what are you feeling from
that how how often have you done it in
the last 90 days real talk
times slow down a bit do you agree with
me that there's an incredible amount of
Discovery for your brand through that
because what Tik Tok does Instagram when
you go live it pings your followers they
come on and then the number goes down
because it's hard to maintain the
audience they have other to do Tik
Tok you go live they keep pinging you
into different feeds while you're live
so you're discovering new people you
agree yeah and when your videos are
trending then uh and you go live it also
starts pinging you and showing those
videos